hey tag ich bin max oder ist willkommen
zu etwas was nicht getan hätte das
gedacht perfekt eine zweite einer perle
es gibt nichts gutes wenn man ändern
meint ist noch ein zweiter ender perle
kriegt weil dann ist man nicht so dumm
in der mitte gefangen sobald man einmal
dort ist sondern kann wieder abbauen und
ja das hoffe man muss sich nicht weil
dieses tolle sachen kriege aber es
könnte ja passieren so jemand anders
noch eine ändert da zu sehen dass wir
ein kreditsystem schon ausgelöst
ok ich richte mich einfach mal aus
notfalls werde ich einfach trotzdem
tatsächlich wollte irgendwie sagen da
bist du trotzdem gemischt hatten wir mal
gegen den guten herrn aber eigentlich
ist einfach so viel los hier in der
mitte
alter schwede aber ich habe ender perlen
gold apple und heiltränke eigentlich
kann es gar nicht viel besser sieht mich
nicht los geht's gar nicht viel besser
ich hatte ganz leicht runter hand aber
der typ ist gut geklappt der typ ist
richtig gute kommt und vergessen wir
aber gute combo nice richtig
ich denke ja weiter slam geschafft sehr
sehr gute leute so viel zu wegrennen
wenn man die mitte auch einfach sagen
kann
naja aber wir werden mal sehen ob wir
perfekt dass hier kann ich mir definitiv
anders lesen und dann alter mein gold
einfach fast kaputt deshalb schadens
eins drauf darf das wäre viel besser
jedoch die leute voll herab damit jetzt
kommen wir ganz bestimmt nicht so
eingebildet aber ganz okay dann
entscheiden wir erst mal alle
ich habe nebenbei noch etwas was ihr
euch erzählen wollte ich habe in der
letzten videos gesagt wie ich so zu
product placement stehe und habe gesagt
wenn wenn irgend was cool ist dann
support ich das auch okay
ich will nicht dass du hier reinkommt
als werder fan angegriffen alter aber
der wald aussieht wie komme ich heraus
eigentlich erzählt was ich sagen wollte
jetzt probiere ich mal runter zu gehen
und dann krieg ich nicht viel braunes
sehr schöne erledigt okay jetzt kann ich
euch in aller ruhe erzählen was ich
sagen wollte ich habe ja eingeleitet wie
ich zu praktischen stehe habe ich gesagt
und da hab ich ja gesagt dass ich wenn
ich was cool finde es ist kein teile und
in einer solchen sache die ich gut finde
eigentlich für euch hat mich die
deutsche bahn angefragt und zwar zu den
deutsche bahn sportcamps die werden geht
es ja ausgerichtet also jetzt mal kurz
bei uns ergeht wie wenn jedes jahr
ausgerichtet und man hat die möglichkeit
sich anzumelden also teilzunehmen und
dann am ende wird ausgelost wer
teilnehmen darf einige haben schon
stattgefunden aber es gibt es nur drei
stück die sind mit turnen handball und
tennis und mit jeweiligen profi
sportlern aus dem bereich und dann könnt
ihr einfach wenn euch wenn ihr euch für
eine von den drei sportlern interessiert
anmelden link dazu gibt es in der
beschreibung
also sechsmal aus und dann könnt ihr
dahin reisen mit einem freund oder einer
freundin und hab kostenlose verpflegung
anreise sonst was also eigentlich einen
kostenlosen kurz sporturlaub wenn ihr
halt ein bisschen glück gehabt und da
gewinnt und das ist eigentlich schon
alles
und sowas finde ich einfach and cool
weil meine jagd spaß dran und ihr könnt
dann sparsam falls ihr sport
interessiert seid und sportlich wäre ich
auch eigentlich ich mache gerne sport
ich bin eigentlich nur immer ein
bisschen faul wenn ich ehrlich bin also
ich war lange im fitnessstudio okay ob
man es glaubt oder nicht wird die kommt
nehmen erst mal nach oben
verdammte gehen aber noch ein einzel
runde kleine ich war auch relativ lange
im fitnessstudio aber irgendwann das ist
halt so schlimm wenn man keine
unbequemen keine regelmäßigen zeiten hat
und dann
irgendwie sich motivieren muss jedes mal
ist gar nichts für mich aber so
teamsport habe ich auch lange gemacht
fußball weiter und wenn ich relativ gut
immer wenn man die kommentare schreiben
macht ihr sport was das euer lieblings
sport bei mir ist das definitiv wolle
weil ich liebe volleyball weil das
einfach sommer für mich und ich mag für
sommer punkt bei der baywa schreibt in
die kommentare was ihr gut finden und
habe ich auch gesagt und jetzt werden
wir einfach probieren diese wunderbare
runde
also wie gesagt wenn ihr bock
abzuschicken tactical ops auszuschenken
perfekte wintergarten bietet das nicht
für möglich gehalten dass ich diesen
schrecklichen attentäter menschen runter
holen kann und distinktion gefallen und
trenne einfach ein kreis auch ich habe
ja jetzt nicht falsch klingen
reisefreunde alter verdammt ich denke
ich den typen machen wenn ich den
runterholen freue ich mich einfach
meines lebens ich freue mich meines
lebens die pizza ist das bitte für ihn
ich hatte nicht mal ein schwert und ich
hab ihn runter gehauen wird mir richtig
stinken wenn ich er wäre aber ich mir
zum glück nicht er sonst wird mir
richtig
ich bin schon leise ich habe echt keine
guten sachen
nicht genau noch unter haben kann
ok schade das wäre zu schön gewesen aber
er hat auch nur noch ein halbes
herzalter wir probieren es aber noch
eine runde außen wir jetzt einfach mal
gewinnen wirklich eins das ist diese
mini karte perfekt geht auch direkt los
und jetzt will ich wirklich mal was
schaffen ich habe ungefähr jeder der
preis spielt nimmt sich dieses element
weil es einfach ist auf dieser karte bzw
ist es ja nicht so wirklich dadurch dass
es jeder nimmt sind dann wieder 3000
menschen in der mitte und man hat dann
doch nicht wirklich was davon möchte
immer irgendwie so in welche vielen
geschichten hier machen und springt in
die luft sprengt in diedorf da unten so
was mache ich immer ich liebe das
irgendwie auch wenn es in der regel
überhaupt nichts bringt weil vielleicht
kann ich jemanden siegen mit meinem
handy ein survival okay ich höre schon
aufzug okay aber ich habe ja gerade
jemand besiegt hey das geht noch ein
bisschen ist das glück oder können
hier schreibt nicht in die kommentare
ich weiß das glück war so ein typischer
pokal
alte wie vom freund ist denn gerade
bitte mein glück hätte wird einfach den
den block entfernt
das soll mir schon gedacht da kommt
nicht mehr rein vielleicht soll es
einfach nicht sein oder vielleicht
probieren wir noch eine runde eins was
ist heute los 1 wo willst du und es ist
auch ein aufwendiges geschnittenes video
hier vielleicht an dieser stelle merkt
aber es ist schon relativ spät
und deshalb möchte ich auch noch
schlafen und möchte noch leben rhede für
ein quatsch briggs ist das auch eine
kleine karte ich weiß ich weiß ja gar
nicht so aber zehn minuten in etwa
bewegen wir uns gerade das dürfte
machbar seien teils werden die runden
drei vier minuten gewinnen dann sind wir
gut dabei geht es auch eine kleine karte
logischerweise perfekt ich liebe das
einfach wenn ich ein mann bin und noch
mal geändert werden kriege das coolste
weil du einfach hin und zurück ans grab
noch einer perle
ich bin einfach der ändert perlen rich
neu und ich glaube es nicht ich hoffe
ist wie sie dass sie es nicht wollen
und das machen wir machen wieder so cool
links mit regenbogen girl packt hier
drin aber ich habe sie geholt
ich habe noch mehr länder perlen mann
ist es soll einfach nur sein freunde du
ich wollte ich gewinnen
trotzdem bin ich schlecht macht's gut